ah well they were different times you
never sexually harassed an a boner have
you question of the day is it possible
that maybe some of us had a blind spot
with rape culture when you see
everything that's going on in the
entertainment industry you see Weinstein
you see Spacey comment below let me know
what you think maybe we need to revisit
rape culture it I think it actually does
exist in one place at the entertainment
industry that is the only place that it
exists I had a friend recently a more
liberal friend from the entertainment
industry saying are you willing to to
relent in the rape culture
um I guess we're talking about Hollywood
the bastion of moral relativism and
cult-like open-mindedness to the point
of being open-minded to evil and anti
science I mean they've been x they've
been absolutely cutting out from their
ranks and chastising any conservatives
Christians any people with a moral
compass so this is the only way I think
it could end up that's why they have a
rape it's press entirely predictable in
fact it is it's not just a rape culture
in Hollywood
it's a good of course culture this is a
big reason it's such a blind spot where
they all believe rape culture yeah they
all believe these myths because it
exists only in their community good
example divorce rates I've written about
this extensively the 50% divorce rate is
a myth it's always been a myth it's
about 25% okay you can go look up census
data and it's it has never been 50% but
so many people believe it because the
entertainment Istria parents and so does
the media by contrast there's one place
Oh two times is likely to end in the
pores like they don't even mean to it so
hollow it's just so crazy to me we go
back in just like Hollywood just not
only have they not aged well in their
world view no they haven't aged well in
their temporary fleeting like I mean
from just three months ago let's take
this cold air remember all of unit a
ministry but Colbert mercilessly mocking
pence after his dinner rules right well
here you go this what he said hence
never eats alone with a woman other than
his wife that can only mean one thing
Mike pants is such an out-of-control
force v Bona came but it has to be
monitored by Karen pence at all times or
maybe it means he's a decent person yeah
maybe means he's smart great respect his
wife but also just just the allegations
right because now we have this such
scenario where they're active they're
celebrities who didn't commit any sexual
assault and they're being accused of it
so this actually mitigates having
principles first off that needs to be
the starting point I know that's kind of
tough let's difficult let's act as
though we all do yeah having principles
first and then also having sound logic
rationalization and also a way to adhere
them that were you okay closet this has
to be consistent because not only am i
doing the right thing but less likely to
be a full salla Gatien so I'm protecting
myself on two fronts and what do we say
he must secretly be a rapist mistake
here's the thing that here's thing we
talk about a lot with liberalism versus
conservatism conservatism consistently
accounts we see that economics when it
comes to government socialism versus a
free-market economy
served ISM accounts for a poor human
nature we're human nature exists whereas
liberals and Catholic tries to pay the
universe as they wish it existed I know
a few drinks I can make some bad
decisions so I'm not going I'm not gonna
put myself in that situation I also know
that she could have I don't know what
her motives are yeah she could want to
do something untoward so I'm just going
to avoid this in here exactly and god
forbid he actually honor his wife making
sure she never has to worry about this
issue right right Mike Pence doing that
at a feminist should be cheering that if
yeah if we have to explain it chicks I
never get it respect when it was he
secretly a pervert yeah secretly he's
wired like a bell he's gay say well Hoss
I can i maybe the Trant no sirree you're
just a [ __ ] what they assumes that
everyone secretly wants to do bad stuff
there doesn't because they're all doing
it's okay just since we report on
Weinstein now Kevin Spacey accused by
fifteen men of sexual assault I mean gay
well because that's that's the smoke
it's a habit just like Stephen Colbert
this is he was very he was very open
about I love it whenever someone just
says something that you know they like
the Second Amendment we just want to
abolish it that guy and MSNBC yeah they
say what you know they were
to say but they here's Kevin Spacey
claiming that he's one of the good guys
is that one of your philosophies in life
yeah be one of the good guys
[Laughter]
yeah it's like Ben Affleck saying I am
absolutely appalled at Harvey Weinstein
but you know that tape is out there yeah
yeah since George Takei busted for
groping an underage model now he of
course denies it
I don't believe him roll clip while
you're using ball because you never
hassled anybody you're great yeah you
ever grab anyone by the [ __ ] against
their will you never sexually harassed
and a boner
have you court you can search the
archives I find many interviews to this
effect him also talking with Artie Lange
or putting already links like a rehab
program because he called someone a [ __ ]
on the show yeah so George Takei sat
there knowing this the whole time are
you really and did PSAs about hate
speech and of course Hollywood gave him
and Kevin speak it was like the most
well known secret I've joked about on
this show about Kevin Spacey being a
sprite they gave him a pass why because
gay because gay that's a smokescreen
that's why it's amazing like you know I
want to confuse gay throw them off the
scent
I don't know about the rape it's okay be
with underage boy it doesn't work that
way but I like this tweet didn't age
well George haha of course recently I
need to immediately remove this tweet he
accused Russian BOTS of setting him up
this was the best tweet initially seemed
nonsensical until we realized that the
new iOS update automatically corrects
BOTS from boys yeah so that makes that
make sense that's a problem with the
software and with George the Kate also
explains some issues for example there
was this famous Star Trek scene
beforehand that seemed out of place
context now again
[Music]
no father no esteem for you you either
leave this bar bloodied or with my blood
on your songs he's a bloodthirsty little
queer and here's the thing do Takei
all through large this this gate or
Kevin's mate same thing as you just saw
was called their regularly talk down to
and about Christians the health of the
economy is what politicians are supposed
to protect not this phony thing called
religious freedom their freedom is just
phony that last argument is just a veil
over a personal prejudice and you cannot
write personal prejudice into civil law
and you certainly cannot write your
religious values into civil law surveil
also was his nickname at the local
Russian bathhouse this clings to you
like a veil this phony theme call for
religious freedom it's almost that is
real it's it's just everyone's
hypocritical if you have any standards
you're hypocrite but Hollywood has made
living off of chastising and off of just
decrying conservative Christians and
anytime the Christians show up in a film
or a Middle American conservative they
are either the completely out of touch
more of a serial killer or they're the
high-school hot cheerleader who treats
everyone poorly because they're not a
part of the cool kids Christian Club
which by the way doesn't tend to be how
it works no we also see it reason with
Lucy Kay he just confessed to forcing
women to watch him masturbate here's
something by the way whenever people
always said that rape was a pop was a
crime of power well no it's actually
it's a crime of sex like there's still
as a sexual component but forcing women
to watch you masturbate I'll give you
that one though it's a cry for power a
comedy skip were a fictional again
conservative Christian Middle American
is against specific and specifically is
mocked on the topic of you guessed it
masturbation you mean that God watches
married people have sex God watches over
everything
so we're like porn for God he watches us
and then he probably masturbates so when
they say oh you secretly have you saying
you're you're secretly homophobic what
they really mean is anytime they accuse
you for petting a rape culture
they're raping somebody in the green
room Lord I've never seen that clip
really he said that well no it's not
real it's a sketch okay yeah but still
case in point this is recent TLC just
cut ties with a guy named Eric Dillard I
didn't know who he was
after the Jazz Jenin comment so I guess
he was involved with a TLC show what did
he tweet jazz is the the young little
transgender for those who take advantage
this is on his Twitter I pity jazz for
those I always get when I read it and
it's the number four yeah it messes me
up yeah just it's like there's 200 no
more matters now there are narrower this
limitations gone I'm pretty sure you
could have written for I hope I pity
jazz for those yeah I still read for
it's the wrong in fact for those who
take advantage of an order to promote
their agenda including the parents who
allow these kinds of decisions to be
made by a child so this is someone a
Christian conservative who TLC decided
to sever ties with this is this person
trying to express their view even though
it's contrarian entertainment entry in
as civil away as they can opening a
conversation saying hey you know what I
really this is what Owen Benjamin did I
don't think this is the right path to go
know what a TLC do well here's her
statement we want to let our viewers
know that Derick Dillard is not
participated in counting on for months
and the network has no plans to feature
him in the future we want to reiterate
that Derek's personal statements do not
reflect the views of the network TLC is
proud to share the story of jazz
Jennings and her family and will
continue to do so okay so let's look at
this this is the moral relativism
chickens they've come home to roost okay
here we have a scenario a guy going
alright listen
transgendered children by the way I love
how far they've reached so quickly I was
like gay marriage okay good we gotta get
that done let's get transgenders in the
bathroom
now let's go up your children everyone's
gonna be on board right and most people
who have an approach and she doesn't
like hold in a second for you who next
transgender fetus is wait they're not
people and to think we actually called
this and they're like no you guys are
alarmist we just won gay marriage that's
it
so this is an entertainment this is
exactly what goes back to sexual assault
it goes back no there isn't a fifty
percent divorce rate it's just you know
there isn't a drug problem everywhere
it's just you know there isn't a rape
culture everywhere it's just you it's
because you feel the need to cut them
excommunicate in this example a man
saying hold on hold on hold on maybe
this is not the healthiest environment
for children TLC thought that was so
offensive transphobic and so filled with
hate speech that they felt the need to
issue a statement saying we stand with
the child [ __ ] star whose parents are
using him /her I don't know I haven't
watch the show to make a profit Jim
listen it's just like this is how you
end up with your divorce rate how you
end up with it with your drug great with
your rape rape how do you think
transgenders end up with a 40 plus
percent attempted suicide rate where
they go through surgery or not you are
enabling them with your moral relativism
because you want to be so open-minded
you have to completely cut out anybody
who provides you with any accountability
and/or standards it's going to end badly
right now we see from the 60s 70s the
exploitation era of film we now see a
rape culture we see a divorce epidemic
we see a drug problem in Hollywood we've
seen those chickens come home to roost
you're gonna see the same thing a couple
generations down the line because of the
whole transgenderism movement right now
people are trying to say hey you should
see the warning signs let's look at this
pragmatically okay you do not have to be
a Christian do not have to be a
conservative you don't to be middle
American people in the entertainment
industry okay you know if you're
watching this do you want to know how
harmful it is for someone like jazz
Jennings okay
take the mental health issues of Corey
Haim and Corey Feldman and Macaulay
Culkin and now that's permanent
hey did you like this video it what you
didn't oh you're a cat person well that
makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video i you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below to as to why you don't
like it